you
haven't been playing much bullet or
hyper bullets
I've been playing too much chess
actually okay here we go an hourly
bullets arena that one crept her right
up on me here we go
hmm let's go with e4
Oh Kahn
all righty you know I like having the
bishop here that whoops I might be in
some trouble okay I want a light square
bishop exchange mmm and giving me some
problems
yeah my Queens defending that pawn now
they missed that still not out of the
woods this guy is super quick
I didn't see that move
when my queen over here
I guess we'll do it like this let's take
care this is collapsing Pont
I could take ooh that's very helpful
actually I thought that that move was
hitting with check it's reading to win
the bishop hmm okay and let's just keep
it really simple this should be plenty
of time yeah I got this no Stanley it's
though no stalemates that
the way he's my tempo guy no Stan let's
move back to tournament okay it's good
to get the first one but yeah I feel
definitely very rusty I lucked out that
I had that well they gave me a piece
Queen takes h3 right let's go Sicilian
lions
and backing up
I'll still try to get in b5 let's just
rule out
some stuff rule out some stuff that's
all I want to do I didn't really want to
give up my dark square bishop oh alright
I don't mind that I gave up that pawn oh
that's um that's a problem you get a
queen trade please Queen trade rook up
got a defend oh they could have cut they
could have they could have captured here
and then captured on f6 I'll take with
the
think not sure why they're giving me
that pawn let's try this take with the
rook I need to defend f6 although flight
Square right
you
I guess we'll centralized have a time
edge but that's about it
I'll take there defend that's all I've
been doing to efense
now I just want to Queen trade they're
gonna lose in time back to tournament I
[Laughter]
am rusty I apologize I apologize you
shouldn't be flying when you're rusty oh
man
shake it off shake it off
okay who juicy juicy f6 I'll take that
now let's make them fight a little bit
more to get that pawn back and they
really struggled Knight takes let's hit
him with a fork maybe
I need to hang on to that guy let's the
other queen feels yeah she's a chicken
running away scared let's just get rid
of him okay we got some juicy stuff now
d6 Knight to e5 or Queen to e5 they
can't put me in a pin they're in check
oh I don't know
flight square and they here looking for
a fork they can move the rook let's just
centralize
get past right let's keep him around I
want to target that guy right now and
get here next I gave up a square but I
get a square
and I could jump around though I like to
play g4 I have a big time edge
let's see take with the pond I get the
night rictus c6 is a killer close to pre
moving that that's what's check yeah
they were just a little bit too slow on
that one
okay andris not our first time what do I
do
let's throw a caro-kann at Andres why
not
okay and we're gonna go Kings side even
though my position is a wreck over here
I'm relying upon this guy to kind of
mend to my structure dropping back to g6
so there we have it Queen here Bishop f4
oh I didn't want to do that hmm I think
I might want to take with the rook
actually and then look for b6 yeah rook
takes pawn might be a movement did I
have that a little bit sooner
might be going for an exchange sack soon
yeah here's the exchange sack there
bishop moves my light
Misha comes to life okay that move is
definitely good it's definitely a good
move can I get this pawn rook move I
have this I'm hitting the pond in the
rook I'll take him
this could be very difficult for them to
win it's probably easier for me to play
even though my bishops kind of silly
keep pressure on this guy
I'm good coordination and a good chunk
of time
I'm not sure why I gave that not sure
why I gave that pawn up there's no good
reason for that this is almost a certain
time when as I drop my rope almost
certain
you
oh I forgot they they've run like the
wind blows towards the end that happened
so many times against him
I I don't know I feel like I have like
at a significant time edge I was a poor
worse position for sure
losing physician probably had stages but
uh what was I going to say I have a time
edge and then it just kicks it into a
whole new gear
catches me off guard all right who's
this guy ah see in London already what
do we do I don't have a light square
bishop maybe we could still look to
break down this structure though yeah
I'll take what upon and how do I want to
take if takes like this probably with
this guy otherwise he could be a target
and what about supergluing the night in
here how they feel about that are we
gonna find out oh I'm also on the rook
but maybe I just go pawn grabbing huh
there in a pin let's jump in here okay
so
my knight you can't put a price tag on
him he's invaluable so we just they're
gonna they're gonna sack definitely
he's too good he's worth five points
okay or not
I'm just looking to break down their
structure a little bit I could have
captured here probably let's do it now
they're way down on time check their in
pins I'll take care not the cleanest
technique by me let's get out of the pin
and then I guess here yeah they were
really down on time yeah it's easy to
eat up a chunk of time when now you have
to try to work around a night on that I
was a d3 square he was a beast
was name
okay heading out the kingside queenside
everything
okay this first
I'm playing this guy ever get some get
some pretty moves in
all right let's keep some pressure on d5
finished development
sneak in a flight square now let's go
opposite the Queen first and I will take
ah aren't they asking for a little just
a little bit of trouble maybe I'm asking
for trouble
let's go here straightaway and I want to
stop okay I don't have to stop Knight to
g4 now if the Queen kept pressure here I
was gonna play h3 I'll take with the
pawn taking with the bishop there's b5
centralized I'll still go in for this I
think I want my bishop somewhere else
okay this is this is nice I could try
for something similar like in the last
game I don't forget it you're going for
this discovered attack against the Queen
just want a queen trade
yeah let's go for it I have two ponds
pawn push bishop here ideas
I guess we'll just exchange and then go
here I want it I want the bishops off
yeah let's go here if I did this I drop
the apon let's do that now
I should probably get pushing these guys
and get moving a bit faster okay I have
three connected ponds three connected
passed ponds and I am floundering okay
you're going here no matter what come on
King
do something good here we go we're
making progress now I just gained a lot
of time
as it's easier to pre move they're down
on time back to tournament
okay all right where do we at here we
got 20 with fire two guys still ahead
here and wow this tournament is flying
by there's only 13 minutes left maybe we
go for some Stonewall action when in
doubt go for the Stonewall the Stonewall
okay gotta watch out my queen my queen I
should have uh what should I have done
okay I could take here first
I just want from my bishop on a secure
square how about this advance not now
let's take here and then here
okay let's just throw a jab at that pun
how they defending it
and she feels cozy over here somehow
let's keep some pieces on Brooke here is
probably good
I just push him gonna go for a queen
exchange okay
I'm passive I am passive I want to get
my knight here their Knight is looking
for this square so he's offset and guess
they're going for a rook exchange can I
get this pawn he's a bit a bit
disjointed
okay yeah that's a good move now I'm
just worse that's a good move that's a
good move now if they pushed that would
have been better I would have been able
to defend this pawn I'm still going to
go here
I I'm just I'm just I'm just winning on
time if you didn't notice yeah oh is
that what you're doing that's how you're
winning these games cuz I couldn't tell
when your your opponents clock goes in
the red I didn't know that that's what
that meant thanks for being specific
let's reinforce my Center all right
Knight you're gonna circle into f6 we're
looking for a dark square stuff
Bishop g5 Queen to d2 trade light dark
square bishop
and yeah let's go in for this so
basically I want to play against this
guy here
we'll keep one rekon and we'll put them
on a safe square let's launch this guy
it's a little bit scary
let's take now
I was ready to go here and that would
have been a painful Fork very painful
and get him out of here I think I think
that's what I want I need to keep the
Queens on um I don't know what I want to
do I don't know what I want man
just move holy cow I didn't know what to
do there I just didn't know what I want
to do okay that's helpful
I may be okay with a queen exchange
actually yeah I think I'm gonna go for
that they're gonna have a tough time
that's a super dangerous thorn of a pond
super dangerous and their Bishop I think
is just cooked yeah he's a gonner they
just resigned in that one hmm
all right we got another one we got 28
with fire 143 in this one he just
finished so we're gonna get andris again
most likely with black let's try
something else
dead of a caro-kann we're gonna go
Sicilian land night ARF
yeah okay let's just take him
line up
okay
I'll take what the pond I haven't
committed my king to the Kings side just
yet he's gone Queen side I'm on my
bishop here can I manage that we're
gonna try my queen might be pretty
pretty nice on that square I'm asking
for trouble if I do that let's uh let's
go here we're gonna repeat
okay I think I'm I think I like my
position it's important I did not budge
with this guy I probably could have held
off on the bishop move for Oh
I don't know could have done something
else I think Oh Queen they're nice and
now I'm just losing now I am definitely
just losing
wait I could okay I'm gonna have to
struggle on with this position
yeah not sure how to take if they take
my rook
yeah this is very difficult
come over here way down on time as well
takes rook can I be sneaky Oh a little
sneak a little sneaky right there it's
not going to help though
terrible save would be it would be
incredible it's not happening now it's
not happening
No
I can resign any time now right now's a
good time ah man that Queen to h5 move
was a killer I said if my e6 pawn budges
I'm in trouble or something like that
and yeah my whole light-square Center
collapsed in a blink the f7 pawn was
kind of important he was a goner
okay let's just get him out of there
bishops way
I'll take him yeah let's remove that
night he's too good
well actually I what did I do
hey yeah I I I faked myself out there I
didn't realize I was on that c5 fun are
we gonna take with the night what are
they doing
listen let's put the push this night out
of the way I have a majority ever since
I won that c5 pawn so let's let's think
about moving that majority
right now okay
next phase is what I can't go here
because the Queen takes Knight rook
takes Queen now I could bishops in the
way here
they might just take the night
let's get my bishop doing something
let's just push them
and
what's my follow-up okay let's win upon
let's wait upon
they're gonna track that guy down I'm
floundering that move I should have
played yesterday a long while ago
okay he's passed maybe maybe he does
something good huh maybe I need I need
some exchanges I get this guy rolling
let's get a flight square in first I
caught up on time here how about that
what's happening there okay now this is
definitely collapsing they resigned back
to tournament that was a backbreaker
they've been berserk as well they got
39:30
holding I'm holding on to second just
barely whoo
any of these guys can still overtake me
the assi in London is this the one where
I ended up planting a knight on d3 I
think this is the same guy okay and
we're still gonna go for this idea even
though I'm playing this time around with
my light-square bishop
hmm let's take like this
and then I guess here you know this is
what I want I want to focus on this
square that's a good move I could have
captured the night
let's try it again and then hop in here
could have won that pond
giving up this pond or yeah I get this
guy at the end I'm gonna go for that
this is this is good
my clean is a beast they were
threatening tricky stuff a mate and a
queen exchange I really don't want a
queen exchange
I really didn't want that how about a
queen here let's do it right now
threatening me no not just yet the queen
is defending that how about now
threatening the bishop
clean here I could do this skewer town
deflection stuff
like this hang on hang on I think they'd
have a check and then a bishop here and
that would hurt
how we try this
I don't know what I want the silly
little check here is bothering me they
don't have any time now they just
blundered okay yeah they're gonna lose
the bishop King g2 Bishop to e4 King g1
Bishop to d3 he slipped up but it's
still gonna be enough he's got seven
thirty to thirty uncreative is there and
so is this guy are they in a game ah
he's in a game
I gotta get I have to get this one
I have to get this game in maybe I
should have reserved it maybe I feel
like I need to try tricky stuff in order
to get this one to count for the
tournament
let's take here maybe they move the
night how about we get my night over
here that should be nice know that night
out of there
okay here I'm on the pond this is not
going to end fast Oh the King is
elsewhere they take the pond they're in
trouble not here okay I'm on the bishop
would they resigned I'm on the Queen and
the bishop would they give me it they're
not giving me I forgot that he's
defended Oh No okay this one's not
counting it's chopped I just got to win
on time can I do that
get out of there men I'm just gonna sack
check check
can I get the Queen I could take my rook
oh I got a second Oh men Wow
just barely oh man am i rusty rusty nuts
holy cow
okay 159 were in that one lucky to get
in second any of these guys seriously
anybody in the top eight first place
could not be caught
the next seven places all had a chance
berserk wiser yeah holy cow
okay let's see how the page is real
quick
it's gonna click I guess there's some
issue it's not letting me see all the
pages okay
anyhow to the 158 of you could games all
fun as usual
you